here's a blackrock president says
entitled generation now learning about
shortages okay this is a bloomberg story
rob capito warned that inflation is
having dramatic effects on the economy
with an entire generation now learning
what it means to suffer from shortages
for the first time this generation is
going into a store and not be able to
get what they want and we have a very
entitled generation that has never had
to sacrifice the economy is reckoning
with the he bubbled he dubbed scarcity
inflation or to follow from a shortage
of workers agriculture supplies and uh
housing and oil in some regions computer
co-founder new york-based blackrock
which is now the world's largest asset
manager with about 10 trillion dollars
in client assets and investments across
the global economy what an interesting
thing to say the entitled generation is
about to learn about shortages well it's
like blackrock are part of the ones who
have screwed people over and so many and
they basically own ten percent of the
world's wealth blackrock it's it's
insane how how deep they go and this is
why it's it's funny when we're talking
about the politics stuff and you know
people arguing about democrat versus
republican and all this is like do you
know what's going on with some of these
elites and the world economic forum
people and these types of people who are
in charge that own so much the the you
will owe nothing and be happy and we're
talking about you know some some things
that just don't really seem to matter
it's like this is what matters it
matters that some
organization like blackrock or vanguard
comes screws you over and then tells you
that it's your fault you know as they're
the ones who are buying up all the
single family homes and turning them
into rental properties so that housing
prices skyrocket and you can't have any
capital yourself
yeah that story from four or five months
ago when you saw that you're sitting
there saying okay remember when tom was
on i don't know if you remember time was
on and tom's okay here's what's going on
here's what they're going to do they're
going to increase trying to convince you
i need to buy now yeah exactly buy now
before these guys pick up a big market
and then you don't have a choice you
don't have another place to go they can
charge you whatever the hell they want
to charge you
but but this inflation thing what he's
explaining the shortages this is not
just that joe biden just came out and
said oh by the way you can expect food
charges shortages because of the
sanctions on russia which to will's
point marjorie taylor green is one of
the only people to have voted against
sanctions on russia because she saw
these things coming yeah she could see
she can look a few steps ahead and say
oh food shortages are probably more of a
problem to american people than russia
invading ukraine now this is not to
condone the russian of invasion of
ukraine but on the flip side like we're
going to have food shortages on top of
the the supply chain issues we had
during the pandemic the fact that our
transportation secretary blows like
there's a whole mess of things going on
that
maybe we don't need to be putting
sanctions on russia can you share with
us your true feelings tyler next time
don't hold back sometimes i know you'd
like this guys i hope you have the show
we do later tyler pull up this guy
rob capito i just want to highlight this
guy because we've all heard of larry
fink he's the ceo
of blackrock you've heard that name
i've never really heard of um rob capito
so
um
just maybe go to his wikipedia so here's
the hypocrisy that i think is just
laughable with this guy right now
new york city elite went to harvard went
to went to wharton 65 year old male 1
specializes in more mortgage-backed
securities
okay
so
which tell the history so people know
where this mortgage
is what brought down that's the big
short yeah exactly what brought down
america to its almost knees in 2008
during the great recession
so like
the millennials are suffering because of
everything that happened in 2008
gen z millennials have been affected by
2008
uh now 2020 everything that happened
with that and here's this
multi-billionaire
new york city elite harvard wharton grad
who specializes in freaking
mortgage-backed securities talking [ __ ]
about millennials like
have a little
like
like understanding of the world and if
you want to come to it from a
financial angle hey you need to save
more you need to invest more i get it
but the whole like they've never had to
sacrifice mother effort what have you
ever sacrificed right so like the
hypocrisy is a little annoying to me
that's my opinion
but other than that he's an awesome guy
exactly i love him yeah we go out for
drinks he's a fantastic guy yeah no the
whole thing with blackrock and those
types of investment firms is really
terrible the people have no idea what's
actually going on but that goes to show
you what he said i think he knows
exactly what he's saying and i think it
goes to show the level of arrogance that
these people have that they know that
they can just get away with whatever
they want like think about on twitter
right now where just like what was it a
year ago with the whole hunter bite and
laptop thing and all that you couldn't
say it new york post got banned and now
new york times and twitter all these
people are saying oh it actually was
true and it's totally fine 500 days
later yeah 500 days later so it's like
oh so you can say all these things or
and and say whatever you want to people
and just have this level of arrogance
and they always just get away with it
they know they're going to get away with
it they know they can get away with
saying this and
and doing whatever they want basically
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]